this is a production of cornell
university
good evening everyone
i'm mike huffman one of the associate
deans in the college of ag and life
sciences and director of the
cornell university agricultural
experiment station the one in ithaca
and i welcome you to tonight's panel
conversation discussion uh title of the
program is facing adversity
farming through unpredictability
also known as climate change
it's a real pleasure to have
some esteemed guests on the panel
tonight
on this side they will uh i'll just
introduce them by name now later on
they'll provide more information about
their farm and background but paul
verscavich
jenny crist
and allison
so my task is to provide a background
sort of a
overview of the topic
and um with that oh
i'd like to acknowledge two people
before we get started and that's
jennifer benson and sharon dietzer both
from cal's alumni affairs and
development for helping organize all
this and get you all here
so let me provide a backdrop to this
topic
let's start with the basics
climate change just imagine the
atmosphere is a blanket
and it's just the right thickness it's
been that way for thousands of years to
retain
you have high energy sunlight coming in
reflected off the earth at a lower
energy it bounces back and forth just
like in a greenhouse so that blanket has
been optimal at about 270 parts
per million of carbon dioxide for
thousands of years and that's why we
have agriculture that's why civilization
is flourished
so keep that concept of the blanket in
mind and things are changing
if you look at the graphs on the right
those are graphs of the three primary
greenhouse gases carbon dioxide on the
top methane and nitrous oxide
and um
again the 270 parts per million is a
good thing it's kept everything just
where we needed to be to be where we are
today as a civilization however in 2012
we hit 394 parts per million that's a 40
increase
in that
of concentration of carbon dioxide and
that blanket is getting thicker
therefore things are heating up the sun
the energy is not radiating back up
this concept of greenhouse gases
several people in the 1800s one guy by
the name of jack kindle came up with
this concept it's pretty straightforward
he was he was my buddy in the high
school track it was fun
um but looking forward to the year 2100
it is likely we're going to have 900
parts per million
by that time and then if you look at the
scale
or that trajectory just imagine right
now at the top chart it says 360 but
that would go to 900 that's hard to
grasp but that's the direction
we are headed
as business as usual without making any
major changes in how we operate
some facts
global average temperatures are
increasing one and a half degrees
since the industrial revolution it's
getting warmer at the poles generally
warming twice as fast as near the
equator
and it's not uniform alaska has warmed
about 7 degrees western antarctic about
10 degrees
the hottest decade ever ever was 2001-10
last year in the u.s it was the hottest
year ever recorded
and we exceeded previous records by one
degree fahrenheit
summers are warmer
and longer
winter is warmer
and again business as usual
we are likely to hit eight degrees
fahrenheit
increase by 2100
just to put it in perspective the last
ice age was eight degrees colder
the evidence is all around us
in the middle if i'm sure you've heard
about this summer
loss of arctic sea ice
it's reduced about 40 percent from
historical records and if you think that
in area that's about the equivalent of
half of the continental u.s
which has always been reflective because
it's totally white now it's deep blue
ocean and can absorb heat there's a bit
of a feed
mechanism potential there
on the right glaciers are retreating
pretty much universally around the world
so why is that important hydroelectric
power 40 of bolivia's hydroelectric
power comes from melting glaciers for
example
in irrigation water
the oceans lower left
are
rising just an eighth of an inch a year
doesn't sound like much
most of the much good part of that is
simply water expands when it warms the
oceans are warming the water is
expanding the balance of that a good
portion of it is coming from more
from the melting glaciers and lastly
upper left anybody hiked been in
colorado in the last two three four
years in the mountains
well i'm an entomologist
and i thought this was amazing
because you'll know that's a photograph
i took but a good portion of the trees
are dead
the reason being
long-term drought
warmer winters warmer summers and bark
beetles love it
and
the scale of that is amazing it
encompasses about 78 000 square miles
from the southern tip of the rockies up
into british columbia and british
columbia there is where there are no
trees left for all dead
okay so kind of a global picture we're
gonna bring it down to the state
so we have challenges more extreme
weather floods droughts high temperature
stress new pests hey things are cool the
southern insects are gonna again i'm an
entomologist job security
but we'll have new invasive species and
it's basically getting less predictable
there's more variability
on the other hand we have some
opportunities we'll have water in this
part of the country
longer seasons warmer seasons what can
we do with that and if you look around
the world around just in the u.s other
parts of the country are going to be
under greater stress agriculture in
california for example
the precipitation patterns in the
sierras is shifting towards more rain
during the winter instead of snow so
there's no banking of a reservoir
of water to tap during the summer and
then throw in san francisco los angeles
and a lot of competition for that water
but again it positions us here a little
kind of on the upside
um
recently well this the scale of this is
from 1870 to now each of those bars
represents a decade
and you can see an increase in heat
stress the degree days over 90 degrees
fahrenheit
and likewise the right side increase in
heavy rains this is two inches in 24
hours
the bar on the far right is 2010.
so lots of challenges but then back to
the opportunities potential to expand
and diversify agriculture new crops new
varieties
winter canola we're growing that in
northern new york for first 19 1990 you
could not do that
california's grape industry is suffering
especially in san joaquin valley because
of the high temperatures are getting too
high sugar content on the other hand
this opens up opportunities for us
double cropping and we have markets 30
percent of the us populations out here
in this part of the country and can we
market this local grown lower carbon
footprint produce good for job creation
economic development
but what do we need to adapt
uh better decision tools for our
producers
when does it make sense to put
additional cooling in a dairy facility
because hot cows produce less milk
when should i switch to a new crop
water management is going to be a big
deal either too much or not enough so
when do i put in additional tiling when
do i buy irrigation equipment and
there's communication strategies among
farmers educators and researchers and
clearly communicating to policy makers
there's adaptation to these changes but
then we can't forget about mitigation
which is reducing our carbon
contribution to the atmosphere
greenhouse gas emissions so on farm
increased energy efficiencies
using less fossil fuel
waste conversion to heat anaerobic
digestion
reduce tillage cover crops and improve
nutrient management are all ways to
mitigate the impact of agriculture on
climate change
so trying to pulling some of this
together
the summary more uncertainty more risk
in the future there's opportunities to
mitigate and adapt
agriculture in new york state is
positioned
to expand and diversify
and we have the capacity look around at
our farmer community cooperative
extension cornell other institutions
and as you will hear from our panelists
farmers are on it they're researchers
they're making decisions every day on
new varieties so we're going to hear
from both
both of the producers on what they're
doing
to adapt and lastly there are activities
in response to this there's new
initiatives across the state at cornell
i've been involved for two years in a
joint pro effort with canadians directly
to the north that somehow climate change
and international borders there's it's
insignificant so they're looking to see
what opportunities they have by the way
75 for their population lives in eastern
canada they've got incredible markets um
we recently started this institute for
climate change and agriculture cornell
there's some new reports out
and clearly cooperative extension as
alison will describe is a resource and
again i'll turn back to our own
producers as a resource of new
information
so with that uh return to the panel i
think jenny's going first
and we're gonna if you don't mind we'll
hold questions until the end
hello
um
my name is jenny crest and
um i
i work with my parents on our apple
orchard in the hudson valley it's
does that sound about right okay
it's uh it's about 600 acres
and
we we actually have about eight
different non-contiguous locations some
are closer or farther away from the
hudson river
and they have varying altitudes also and
so we get to observe some of the
different climatic impacts
but anyways
i
i sort of categorize some of the
different ways that the changing climate
affects us
via earlier springs hotter summers
milder winters a longer growing season
and more severe storms so i'll just go
through each of those things
so earlier springs there's been a lot of
press about the the frost and how it
damaged the apple crop this year um
there's different ways it damaged the
crop you can see the
which one's the point
um
the those apples are actually dead
they're brown inside those are the baby
apples um but then there can be scarring
the quality issues on apples that are
actually
you know reach harvest maturity
um
and that's all because you know the
apples are much more prone to frost once
they're at a susceptible stage so if the
springs are earlier because we have a
mild winter
and this past winter we started seeing
spring in march then the
the apples reach a susceptible stage
much earlier in the year
and we're more
more more prone to the cold weather
and actually
dr
uh art degatano has done some research
about um
the the killing frosts that have been
occurring
and
he's predicting that
the the frost risk is going to increase
through time um and
there's probably going to be we
categorize it by 10 percent kill or 50
percent kill or 90 percent kill of the
apples
but there's probably going to be
about the same number of 10 kills but
more 50 and 90 kills um
just because of the variability of the
weather
so
um
so anyways ryan and i on the way up
we're trying to figure out the ryan's
our firm credit loan officer and we're
trying to figure out the uh
the
the difference in yield between a good
site and a poor site and how much extra
you could afford to pay for a good site
over a poor site to prevent against
frost um
and so
it's very interesting this year we
actually
we we could really see the difference in
a good site and a poor site a good site
had pretty much a full crop like maybe a
thousand bushel per acre and a poor site
could have so little that we didn't even
bother to pick it um so almost zero
um
but anyways we we averaged like 500 or
500 bushel per acre difference and if
you take an average market price in a
good year when there's a short crop of
14 per bushel
and then take out your variable costs so
do a 30 gross margin that's about 2100
dollars
just for the difference in yield not
even counting the difference in quality
and that's really interesting because
when you go to purchase a new site you
might want to take that into
consideration
as far as what you're going to what
you're willing to buy an acre for and
what you're planning to grow because the
frost event won't occur every year but
if it occurs once every 10 years
or if it occurs you know twice in 20 you
you might want to figure that in the
2100
and then you can add the quality
contribution on top of that too
uh there's some more examples of hilltop
sites in the hudson valley
planting on the hills
um the other thing we do for for uh
frost before i get to the summer part um
once you know when there is a frost
coming we we have a wind machine
we've also tried out some helicopters
the helicopters are are really hard to
manage
it's a less consistent result and you
have to work closely with the pilot
my dad had a lot of fun with them in the
middle of the night last week last
spring
but it's very expensive it can be three
hundred dollars to a thousand dollars
per hour um
being on standby can cost a lot of money
um and then you really need to we had
them work up the hill so as it got
colder three nights in a row in late
april they moved up the hill to cover uh
the higher and higher ground as we gave
up on the lower ground but in the end it
was really hard to measure the benefit
that they did or didn't give
and we were frustrated with our ability
to get the helicopter right where we
wanted it we would have preferred to
drive it ourselves
but um
the
the wind machines are a more consistent
result and we can see the difference
between the areas that we didn't didn't
have the wind machine at similar
elevations
and they cost about 30 to 40 40 000 to
install and they can maybe protect about
10 acres but then they also require a
significant amount of fuel but those are
becoming more techy which is interesting
you know you can have them
come on automatically when it reaches a
certain temperature and things like that
if you get the newer the newer kind so
those are some different things some
different options to consider
and it of course it all depends on the
specifics of the night about whether the
there's an inversion because if there's
no warm air up above it doesn't help too
much
but and then there's also the
consideration about crop insurance um
if you
first of all we think it's a really
important thing to buy crop insurance
but then there's a you know the
different levels you can choose um and
if you have crop insurance your the
amount you're willing to invest in a
helicopter or in a wind machine is
probably a little less than if you
didn't have crop insurance and ryan and
i tried to figure out what that level
was too but it's really tricky
so because there's a 50
deductible on the crop insurance and so
it gets really hard to figure but
it'd be easier if you knew exactly what
temperature it was going to be that
night and exactly what impact that would
have on the crop
um
but then so hotter summers um
as mike was saying you know we have we
have longer hot spells
the heat waves are more intense and more
frequent an increased frequency of
drought um
i had to make sure my dad wasn't going
to be too embarrassed if i showed these
pictures
this is raw on honeycrisp and
it's it's caused probably by a few
things but especially by sunburn which
allows the rot spores to get in
it damages the surface of the apple and
kind of cooks it
but that can be
aggravated by a lack of water also
and actually the surface temperature of
the apple can be 30 degrees higher on
hot days than the air temperature so if
it's 100 degrees out the surface of the
apple can be 130 degrees
and so that
that's a lot of stress especially on
this delicate variety but we've also
only been growing honeycrisp for about
10 years so it's not something we've
seen a big change in over the course of
the climate change discussion
but it is something we factor in with
the
the warmer summers
so
one thing that we do is you know a lot
of drip irrigation just to relieve the
stress on the trees because you can see
the the high density plantings that
we're transitioning to in the apple
world
this is a second leaf tree on the tall
spindle terence robinson's new planting
style from cornell and so they those
trees were planted the previous growing
season and you can see the apples on
them which is pretty amazing and there's
a drip line in there
but there's not a huge root system and
those little trees are already producing
fruit and so they really they really
need the support of the water to grow
the tree and also to grow the apples and
there's a lot of research
that the more
the the more stress there is on the tree
the more stress there will be on the
fruit and the lesser the the quality of
the fruit
and the yield that's another block that
that block is older probably like five
or six years old
and you can see there's there's just not
a lot of tree structure there for the
amount of fruit and so you really have
to keep the water applied
so the other thing uh that's interesting
you can irrigate of course overhead for
uh
for frost frost control freeze control
and in washington they also overhead
irrigate uh they do evaporative cooling
to cool down the fruit and prevent loss
of water in the orchard on the hot days
so we're thinking of trying something
like that on our honeycrisp but
um on a high value crop of course
honeycrisp sold this year for like 80 a
bushel in a normal year a good uh bin of
cider apples is like ninety dollars for
you know a whole bin
but honey crisper a high value high
value crop
um
um we're also with the hot summers
experiencing with our experimenting with
some sun protectants they're mostly
calcium based it's kind of like a
sunscreen on the apple i don't have any
pictures of that but
you just have to be really careful that
it will wash off and it can also
impact color development on the apple
we've tried it on a lot of honey crisp
and some of the color hasn't developed
quite the same
but it needs to wash off otherwise it
looks like the apple has spray all over
it even though it's just calcium it's
not very appealing to the consumer
um
anyways the the milder winters is the
the next uh next thing and i guess the
the milder winters impact us a little
bit less they're on average four degrees
warmer than the 70s according to cornell
we do have to wait a little bit longer
for the trees to harden off if we start
with a milder winter before we start
pruning this year and last year we
waited at least a month longer before we
started our serious pruning
because a if you make a big wound in the
tree
before it's hardened off you can get
winter injury when it cools down
also the milder winters can encourage
the deer population this is our new deer
fence we put in last winter
it's eight feet tall we saw a deer jump
over an eight foot tall fence so don't
do a six foot tall one
if you're gonna do it but it cost about
fifteen thousand dollars a mile we did
seven miles of it
and we figured out based on the area
that was enclosed it was about six
hundred dollars an acre but it can
impact production like by about 25
we have a farm that's had a deer fence
for a number of years and we just saw
the production climb up and up in the
years after the deer fence was installed
so we're pretty big believers now four
of our locations have deer fences in the
return on investment for a deer fence
so this is one of the nice things about
climate change we have a longer growing
season and we never thought we could
grow pink ladies before but we can um so
these are
in their
third leaf i think and
we we have beautiful pink ladies
the one thing that we've experienced
with them is because of the longer
growing season the insects have more
time to get to them and you have to end
the summer disease and you have to
protect those apples longer
some insects can have a third generation
that didn't used to have a third
generation as you have a longer
growing season
so we have to keep staying on top of
that
we also 20 years ago we never thought
we'd grow fujis but we've been fuji's
are actually harvested before pink
ladies so they're a no-brainer now but
as it gets warmer they can grow them
more in western new york and other areas
farther north
so
um
and then
the uh
the last thing
um
these are
i i believe more severe storms are
associated with climate change and i'm
not sure if that necessarily means hail
but there is more rain and more wind um
and
this is what can happen if your trellis
system isn't good enough on a hill
and then
my dad ends up doing that
as long as the tree can be salvaged but
one thing we've learned is with you know
as we switch to these higher density
plantings that we really need a
a stronger trellis system that will hold
that kind of weight
especially when we get these high these
high wind storms and
the soggy ground and the shallow root
system on a big hill like i showed you
at the beginning so
we really have to build for that
um
one of our jamaican guys told us we
weren't thinking very much when we set
these up
um and then hail of course um i'm not
sure if that's particularly associated
with climate change but it tends to come
with strong storms sometimes and there's
not an awful lot we can do it about that
unfortunately um except to diversify our
locations that's one reason we have uh
so many different locations and we're
spread out it might be more convenient
to be on one spot but it diversifies the
risk a little bit and then the the crop
insurance is really
really really important when it comes to
hail
so
in summary
i guess the most important thing is to
invest wisely in your sites for
elevation and air drainage but also for
water
because as we
you know have bigger longer droughts or
hotter summers and want to use
evaporative cooling we need to have the
water available
and really think through carefully it
might sound like a big number per acre
that you
would would have to invest to have the
nicer site but it might be worth it
especially looking at climate change
um and if you can
diversify in location to spread your
risk that's also very important for
severe storms
and then invest wisely in your plantings
too choose the the site carefully to
match uh match the variety so like we
put our pink ladies on the southern
facing slope on this farm farthest to
the south and we put our honeycrisp that
suffer from the the heat we put them on
the north facing slope on the farm nor
farthest in the north
so between choosing the varieties that
the market wants and then placing them
carefully on your different locations to
have the best
the best return it's really important at
ten thousand dollars or more per acre by
the time you set it all up you can't
afford to make a lot of mistakes
planting
buy crop insurance
and then carefully consider the the
frost control measures um
and in the end i mean a lot of the
things that
i talked about with the climate change
they're good management practices in
general and things that
farmers have been doing for a while we
may need to do them more frequently now
or to a larger a greater degree
but i just wanted to point out that
climate change it's a risk that we face
we're dealing with it step by step it's
a gradual change but there's a lot of
other risks that factor into business
management
you know one of our biggest business
risk right now is having an affordable
and legal labor force and willing labor
force
and then you know it's great we have
cornell and extension we
uh and they help us through you know
these climate change issues and um
the hudson valley lab is there for us
every every spring when we're
confronting things like the frost and
giving us the heads up on on everything
but
they send daily emails and are always
available but the research on the stink
bug and
some of the different insects and the
extended life cycles of the insects
is really important so um
we're we're glad that cornell's there
for us so
um and that's it
i'll pass it on to paul
okay uh yeah my name is uh paul
roskowicz i'm a fourth generation onion
grower from orange county new york i
farm in partnership with my father
and you know thinking about uh
you know different weather patterns and
farming through unpredictability i
thought i'd just share some of the
experiences that we've had over the last
two years because weather has certainly
had an impact
in our area
not so much for the good
so i think i'll
start off well back up a little bit i
mentioned i'm an onion grower that's
primarily what historically what we've
grown
however
two years ago we started growing
some winter squash
and pumpkins and we've grown some corn
and soybeans on and off over the years
so anyway
i'm going to start with last season
2011.
last season was an extremely wet year
right from the beginning it seemed like
we were fighting the wet
all season long we had some onions that
we planted it was so wet they rotted we
ripped some up we planted squash
um
and all season long stayed wet and then
of course that was uh
ended in august by hurricane irene and
tropical storm lee where we had uh
eight to nine inches of rain in less
than 24 hours and with the soil already
being saturated of course we flooded
um
on our farm we lost uh about 85 percent
of the crop
um dollar value somewhere around three
hundred thousand so uh need to say it
was a pretty hard hit
uh there were some growers in valley who
lost their entire crop so
um um one one advantage uh that i did
have last year is uh
i planted about eight acres of squash
and upland uh outside of the muck so of
course that didn't flood and that was
the only squash i ended up
selling last year
so uh as a
result this past summer um 2012
i did grow some more squash and upland
we had approximately 20 acres
um
and of course that presents other
challenges with wildlife uh you know
jenny mentioned challenges with deer we
had deer and woodchucks um
which did quite a bit of damage on uh
i had one four acre field is the poor
location because uh right next to it was
our uh neighboring dairy farm we had his
uh his bunk silo so the
the deer would go to the eat some silage
and they'd come into the squash field
and then he went down the hill and onto
the muck and ate pumpkins so
anyway i won't i won't be uh growing
that field next year
but
anyway
this growing season was actually a
fairly decent growing season and started
off a little on the dry side
but we were able to get an early start
it was a good growing season until we
got to the fall and this fall was
extremely wet
which resulted in serious quality issues
in our onions
seems the the first onions we harvested
were very good but anything harvested
after a certain date
just sort of broke down
and
we had a lot of waste and um
not only that but the weather stayed wet
for so long we didn't have any good
drying air to to help dry the crop so
that contributed to it
also uh this year with squash um
we did have a an early frost very hard
frost in early october so i probably
lost um about 12 acres of butternut
squash some of the other squash was a
little heartier so that was all right
but we did have a lot of
problems harvesting just because of wet
weather
not only because of the weather but
we're also faced with a
labor shortage
i know it's tough around the state but
particularly in orange county uh we had
a difficult time getting uh labor in the
fall to pick so
uh you know normally i can line up day
crews come pick squash when it's ready
to be picked um but this year i had a
hard time finding day crews and then
days when i could get a crew and it
ended up raining and couldn't pick
so um
that was a challenge
um and looking back at you know some of
the quality issues we had with onions i
think
a lot of that
stems from last year
with the flooding anytime you have a
flood you have all kinds of bacteria
and other pathogens
coming in with the flood waters
and
on top of that we had a very mild winter
last last winter so
things didn't freeze
to kill a lot of the pathogens as you
normally would have if you had a nice
nice hard freeze so this one we've had
some cold weather i'm hoping we get some
more
so
anyway
thinking ahead to next year
i'm going to be cutting back some on
squash
i'm not so much worried about the
weather as i am
about labor with the squash because
you know you can grow it but if you
can't get it picked it doesn't do you
any good
i'm also going to be uh
growing some more corn and soybeans
one thing i've noticed you know you talk
about
warming temperatures and opportunities
for new crops
i'd say you know 10 years ago you
probably saw very few if any soybeans
grown in orange county
i know just this past summer there's
been at least two grain bins that have
gone up
around the county so uh there's there's
quite a few
more acres of soybeans uh being grown
um
and uh i will also
continue to grow uh some on up land uh
although not as much um
and uh sort of to to summarize things uh
you know thinking about
um
you know severe weather patterns and
just
farming through unpredictability uh i
think
um you know whether you're dealing with
climate change or not mother nature is
always going to throw you a curveball
even in a normal year whatever that is
anymore
um
and so i think
it's uh you know one thing i've learned
it's good to be at least a little bit
diversified so that you can spread your
risk out over more than one crop when
you have all your eggs in one basket
uh particularly with a high value or a
crop like onions where you have uh
pretty high input costs
um
it's good to diversify a little bit
and also i think uh in general you just
need to be
willing and able to uh adapt to change
um
particularly to um unpredictable events
whether it be
weather related or regulatory or or
whatever so
um that i think i'll turn it over
thank you
well good evening my name is alison
jotharchon and i'm from dutchess county
cooperative extension
and i think we're gonna pull up my talk
here
great thank you so thank you for having
me here um
is there this is the clicker yes okay
so i thought i'd start off with a short
video and i might have to hit the
so i've been very fortunate to be
working half time
for the last
almost two years on a new initiative
that we're very fortunate that helene
dillard this is a production of cornell
university
can we
okay so i've been working on a new
statewide cooperative extension team and
this
is
providing halftime funding for five
educators around the state we have
someone working on agriculture
specifically mary reggae in oneida
county
my focus on is on climate change and so
i've been working with cornell
university faculty to develop new
outreach materials on climate change to
bring them out to our extension
audiences and so this is one of the
new mechanisms that we're using to reach
out to farmers
and i'm only going to show a little bit
of it this is a production of cornell
university
we've been very lucky on fishkill farms
not to
have any severe effects from the big
storms of
last year
but our neighbors have certainly had a
lot of trouble across the river in
ulster county there was tremendous
damage and it's not only from
the irene
uh
storm and the hurricanes it was also
um
there have been wind and hail events
throughout the last couple of years that
have periodically caused cause
and the october snowstorm um knocked
over a lot of trees as well so
and broke a lot of branches
so yes there have been quite a few
events
that are quite severe and we're seeing
you know big swings on the
the rainfall side as well between
drought and
prolonged periods of
extreme
extremely heavy rainfall
just that just gives you a brief
overview and we did hear from jetty and
she's a similar uh fruit orchard farmer
in the hudson valley the reason i show
that is that we're just starting
new ways of reaching out to farmers and
doing some of these short video clips
that we'll be posting on
climate change website at cornell so i
think it's important to keep this
nifa priority in mind that as we see a
changing climate
we need to help our agricultural system
help our farmers adapt to a changing
climate
while maintaining their economic
vitality and so that's what our program
work team is doing at cornell and our
statewide team
and so i think it's also interesting
there was a recent study of farmers done
at iowa state university it could be
possible to do a similar study of
attitudes of farmers in new york state
to
really understand scientifically what
their knowledge is of climate change and
in iowa actually 66 percent of farmers
indicate they believe climate change is
occurring however only eight percent
believe it's caused by humans uh 35
believe it's equally caused by humans
and natural causes 25 percent due to
natural causes so really while it is
positive that 66 percent of farmers
believe that climate change is occurring
now we do still have some work to do in
our communication and our outreach in
providing the research that's taking
place at cornell out to the stakeholders
that we work with and so i mention our
new statewide energy and climate change
team i would encourage you to contact
your local educators in your local
office talk to your cooperative
extension boards
boards of directors and your agriculture
agents see if they've gone through
training and if you have questions about
extreme weather events they can
certainly contact our team or or contact
researchers or cornell
i've been working with what i mentioned
is a program work team on climate change
and this really is just a mechanism
where faculty
our staff and our extension educators
can come together
usually in person twice a year and then
we have
communications and other
work teams that are working on
committees and this allows us to
better communicate to each other about
research about funding opportunities we
recently submitted an epa environmental
education grant that will provide a
funded
climate change education for several
different
enrolled volunteer programs including
master gardeners so we hope that kind of
collaboration will help bring more
funding to cooperative extension into
cornell researchers
and i mentioned that we're we have been
working on new communications
outreach we've been at empire farm days
at the new york state fair we've been at
fairs like the duchess county fair
i did a similar talk for our
agricultural breakfast where we had 100
people in the room to talk about extreme
weather and i think you're going to see
an increase in this type of
communication from cooperative extension
and so
i'll end with
some win-win benefits that i think both
of our producers talked about that
really
taking on some of this work to start
thinking about climate change is
good
for farmers because it can reduce risks
and help prepare for extreme weather you
can take advantage of the opportunities
that michael mentioned
you can improve your operations and
upgrade infrastructure and there are
several incentive programs
for new york farmers through nycerta
and you can
contact cooperative extension if you
have questions about that
we can help promote local sustainable
economic growth through
local food systems biofuels and
production agriculture here in new york
and help support our communities and
become more sustainable in upstate new
york and throughout new york state
and with that
this is a production of cornell
university
have you seen any local effects of
extreme weather and and climate change
in in the years especially especially
because you you're native here to
dutchess county uh yes i have it seems
like the
winters are getting much milder
we're getting more i think more severe
weather as we head
south seems to be getting more snow more
cold winters are not nearly as bad
we've had three major weather events in
the last couple years one two years ago
the excessive snow throughout the winter
last fall with the uh you know being hit
by
tremendous amounts of rain the hurricane
and then this winter with i don't
ever recall a winner of this uh
as easy as it was i've gone through
snowless winters but never with as mild
as it's been we didn't have a winter
actually and we didn't have a winter and
i see
a lot less hay was fed a lot less hay
was used uh
which is you know a double-edged sword
it's good for those that didn't have to
buy hay but it's
poor for those of us that sell high
or it's it's an issue uh
what the insect population
and the
bad
bugs that weren't killed uh
in today's paper there was a major thing
about uh
you know lyme disease being
you know perhaps the
banner year for lyme disease so i'm i'm
really
concerned over what's coming down the
road even though i can't
predict
i can only hope that things won't be as
dire as they may be
what happened to your farm during the
extreme weather events and how much
money you think
you lost how did it affect you
uh
of course it started in in april last
year with the fact that we had so much
trouble getting the crops in uh
just you know we got them seated and we
couldn't go even go back and roll them
roll them pick up rock
uh
which in turn we probably got a poor
catch a seed than we should have
so that that bothered us you know just
little little things that
you know don't always add up the fact
that you have to send
people
again and again back to the field
because there's big wet spots you have
to go around and stuff like that it
takes a lot more time
we lost probably half our old crop
because we couldn't get it we couldn't
harvest it in the window that we had it
went down we lost a lot of it
the biggest thing that's bothering me
right today is that we left probably
fifteen thousand dollars worth of hay
uh
second cutting grass hay in the field
that we could not harvest last fall
we made
many attempts we got some in but we knew
a lot of hay so we we left fifteen
thousand dollars with the hay in the
field which is really financially
bothering me right now strapping me
uh we lost a field of corn
that was
you know a lot of it was management
fault for not chopping that field we
left it for grain thought we could get
it and we got the late
snowstorm and it was very tall corn and
it took it down so we lost
we lost a lot of corn over there so we
probably lost
a minimum of forty thousand or solid
crops
you can as a farmer you can
you can weather the storm
but you can't weather continuous storms
uh you can you can take it on the chin
you can uh
you know you you come back spring brings
eternal hope and that's as a farmer
that's what's that's what fuels me
that's what you know as i
as i become alive i mean this winter you
know and
as the warm weather comes you we all
feel like doing more and as a farmer
it's just so much easier you know we we
think again this year i have this
probably a skewed vision that this is
going to be the best year ever
so that's a nice way to end hope springs
has been a production of cornell
university
so i we are doing these video short
video clips as a way to
have farmers speak to farmers and they
will be up on the cornell
climate
change.cornell.edu website and we're
hoping to engage other cooperative
extension educators around the state to
go out and do the you know talk to their
farmers and and the farmers that they
work with and capture some of more of
these videos so that you know we're not
the ones
out there preaching to farmers but they
can talk to themselves and these are
some of the resources that we have
available there there were fact sheets
out in the front and with that um we're
gonna
have a conversation i think
you i guess i admitted i was an
entomologist earlier
i'll make a few assumptions that the new
conditions weather etc are aggravating
pests in general so if we have a similar
set of circumstances then i wouldn't be
surprised if it happens again
that's the best i mean obviously i can't
predict the weather but
uh it's these
unusual wealth wet spells coal spells
whatever interacting together and that
sometimes it's just like i mentioned the
bark beetles you know just perfect and
insect populations take off it could
also be
i don't think that's migratory but i
mean we're also having new storm fronts
come through that also bring in pests
yes claire
um
well this is on everyone hear me um
yeah it's it's always been a challenge i
think uh communicating with uh with
consumers um there seems to be a
you know a growing disconnect between uh
the farming community and and the rest
of the community um especially as
there's fewer and fewer farmers
um but one one thing i did notice last
year with a hurricane
um being that we had such extensive
damage in orange county uh the local
community and consumers really really
took notice
of uh you know what we were going
through and
you know they did a
number of community events they did a um
sort of a local uh farm aid
uh
in the community and i think they they
started out with the goal of raising 20
000 by
the 20th of whatever month it was
and uh
they ended up raising uh just over a
hundred thousand um and they they
had a big event um sort of an
educational event um where the community
could come in you know talk directly to
farmers they had you know various
exhibits uh set up so i think
um it took an event like that where
consumers at least locally um
took notice of what what the farmers in
the area were going through but
yeah it's
it's
well there you know the frustration of
trying to communicate um
our problems and
not not only our problems but how uh
how produce gets to the shelf and
you know even though we have a severe
shortage locally it's always going to be
there in the supermarket and um
and also there's it seems to be one
thing i did notice
you know there's this myth out there
that all farmers get subsidies
and crop insurance i was talking to
somebody you know they mentioned crop
insurance they said well don't you have
crop insurance says well yes i do say
well did you get anything from that i
said yeah we received about i think 80
000 from
crop insurance and he said wow that's
quite a bit of money
i said yeah but our seed bill alone was
120 000 so
it's very
and
you know that was a shock to them um so
i think um
i don't know it's a challenge jenny i
don't know
um
i know
uh we were we were pretty careful when
the frost first came not to say too much
to the papers because you never know the
extent of the damage and you don't want
people to write off the farm markets and
not to come so
we actually were pretty conservative in
how much we told that story
and
just as a side note my parents were out
in washington state about a month ago
and that's the number one apple
producing state in the u.s and
they were just delighted out there
because they're filling into our markets
they were just dancing around with joy
but
it's not entirely bad we do have a food
system that can can handle the
variability and the different you know
the climates and the different geography
and we don't have to go hungry but
it is a little scary for next year's
markets
i wouldn't say i don't worry about it
because uh of course i do i think every
farmer worries about it
um
but
you know like you're saying uh like i
mentioned diversification i think uh
particularly with more extremes in
weather the more you can diversify
yourself you spread that risk out a
little bit
in other words if i i plant
fewer acres of the more intensive crops
such as onions and squash
i can grow corn soybeans there's a
little bit
less input costs there plus you don't
have the labor aspect of it
and
i think you know with today's grain
prices those crops have been
a little bit more profitable than they
have been in the past
so i think diversification is part of
that
but i think you know as any farmer knows
you have to
you have to be willing to accept risk
because if
if you didn't
um well you wouldn't be in this business
i know
years ago my grandmother was a great
cross stitcher and she uh she did this
one sampler and said
if you think there's gambling in las
vegas just try growing onions
all around the borders they had thrips
and disease and all the different things
that can that can can affect the
onion drop so
right it's part of the game i guess
um i don't know if i have a good answer
i i guess uh it's true i think it's
becoming more and more capital intensive
all the time and there's always new
technology we have an electronic defect
sorter that picks out apples with marks
you know spots on them now on the
packing line electronically which is
pretty cool but it's also pretty
expensive and we also have a or we would
like to get a half a million dollar
internal defect sorter that shines light
through every apple and sees if there's
browning on the inside
but that's a pretty expensive price tag
um
and it at some point i think it'll
become just something we have to have to
market our you know certain crops in the
springtime when there's a risk of
internal browning after long-term
storage and customers will just expect
that we you know that we're able to
detect that so it's pretty scary i mean
i think it's one reason we really need a
strong crop insurance program
i know it's you know it's not always
enough but it's at least it keeps you
from having to dig out of quite such a
big hole
because you can't afford
you know next year we want to invest in
the next thing we don't want to dig out
of last year's hole so
you know you're dealing with an
insurance program where you have to take
the first 50 of the loss so that's i
mean
you'd be crazy if you bought an
insurance program like that for your car
or your house because it just just
wouldn't work
um
you know i think
you know maybe crop insurance has come a
long way but i think it probably has a
long way to go yet before it's uh
an effective tool um
you know like for onions we buy crop
insurance because
if you don't have insurance you don't
qualify for any type of disaster aid
should that come down the line
um you know i mentioned you
you have to take the first 50 of loss
you can buy up at substantially higher
premiums um but that just
my opinion doesn't pay either i've
talked to some growers one year
i know i talked to one grower
the payment he received didn't cover his
premiums so
how was that how was that an effective
tool
i'm not sure i think even though i
wouldn't like to spend the extra money
we might have to just to ease the
variability
just like if you were to have a fire you
know you buy fire insurance every year
but hopefully never have a fire
um
i i don't know i sure wouldn't want to
pay 60 more because it's already pretty
expensive but
um
i think i think we might have to um
either that or ask farm credit to
capitalize losses you know in the years
when they
i guess you can do it either way maybe
depending on your banker
well i know a number of years ago i was
reading an article somewhere and
the they're trying to make the point
that
one way or another
consumers are going to have to pay more
for their food whether they pay more at
the grocery store or they pay higher
continue to pay higher subsidies because
uh you know like i said that
the capital that goes into agriculture
these days is uh you know pretty intense
and that then again goes back to the
disconnect between consumers and farmers
a lot of consumers just don't
understand what it what it takes to uh
to grow a crop or to produce food these
days
um
i i think my parents and i usually see
pretty eye to eye on it
actually we just fixed a fixed our
interest rates on a couple of of our
bigger loans
and we were pretty much in agreement
about that
you know we try to
manage some risk and
leave some you know leave some variable
um on the interest rates but then
um on the cropped crop side too you know
you buy crop insurance but it's still a
risky business
um so
i i guess we just look at the the
benefit that we could have from from uh
from trying to mitigate some of the risk
and then the cost of doing that
um
i think
you know uh
perception of risk kind of varies not
only throughout generations but also
throughout individuals um
because i remember taking farm
management and college you know talking
about how uh
you know as the older generation
progresses they get less willing to take
on risk whereas the younger generation
is is more willing um
in case my father
uh i'm not so sure that's true he's
still he's still willing to roll the
dice every year and uh i know he's uh
he's always been forward thinking and
looking ahead to uh next year and i know
over the years he's probably made it
several sacrifices to uh
you know keep us going probably for my
benefit
um so and
you know like jenny mentioned it's
important to have a good working
relationship
you know we talk constantly discuss
these things so um
it's i i think it varies a lot
between businesses and between
individuals
we try to work out all the numbers and
then take a look at it and
make a decision i'm glad that my parents
still make some of those decisions
because they're kind of tough ones
yeah it's sort of an interesting debate
i don't know but i think we ought to
have that debate oh absolutely um i
you know there's i don't think anyone's
gonna argue that we're we're not seeing
more uh
uh
extremes in weather because we certainly
are
um whether you know you
you believe that's due to uh
global warming climate change or if it
just seems to be a
a cycle in a
much larger macro sense
i think there's still a lot of debate
there
um but
yeah i mean we need to continue to have
that debate because uh you know whether
or not
climate change is real uh or how much of
it is uh man-made i think it's uh it's
certainly having an impact on
agriculture
and
i think you know we're gonna have to
respond to it
in some way i don't know
if we're gonna have electric tractors
but i think just uh
agriculture in general is getting more
efficient you feel costs are going up so
of course we're gonna burn
um
look for ways to burn less anyway
yeah i think a lot most farmers are
driven to be efficient by nature um just
you know to save on costs i also worry
that if we have a lot of regulations
imposed on us about climate change
that that we will be less able to
compete with the rest of the world and
like like you were saying before
you know
mexico and china they'll backfill the
food industry
they'll keep the grocery store shelves
full
and
probably what they're doing won't be as
environmentally sound as what we were
doing before so we just we have to be
very careful what we impose on our
farmers i think
but that said i i mean there's maybe
things we should be doing but
maybe it should be more on an
encouragement level than regulatory
we actually had a farm three hours to
the north of us uh when i was a little
girl
my parents did because macintosh grow
better up north
but we struggled because transporting
them back down without bruising was was
really difficult so we we sold the farm
after a few years i think
um
but yeah they we we thought about that
and now we're just tearing macintosh out
but we found a new a new strain that
grows better the ruby mac but
when we've talked we haven't ever talked
really too much about doing that again
because we tried it the one time when
we've talked about relocating it's been
more a discussion about labor
than about climate change
yeah that
that's
i i think probably does make some sense
diversify geographically to
farm in various locations however uh
um from a management side it gets to be
be very difficult um you know if you're
i you know i have no one grower he's uh
this year i guess he's growing some
squash down in the dominican republic so
he's flying back and forth and i just
can't imagine the
the headaches and the costs associated
with some of that i mean certainly
there's advantages but
it's it's a tough thing to do
it's enough trying to handle one
operation
in one country
try and spread that out
okay thank you all and let's give a
round of applause to our panelists
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu